Batman and Superman meet the
anti-superman what does that even mean
okay so what this story does is this
picks up in an alternate universe
version of Gotham City which is
technologically advanced and it looks
really really cool but the funny thing
about this little bit of a story here is
that this basically mirrors the story of
Superman and that's something that's
going to become important here in a
second that within this alternate
reality version of Gotham the world's
basically coming to an end so much like
the story of Superman this kid is put on
a rocket ship and sent away here's the
big difference between this kid's story
and the story of Superman when Superman
was sent away from Krypton and he
arrived on Earth that took place within
the main DC universe itself when this
kid sent away he actually ends up
traveling through the Multiverse and
arriving in the main DC universe itself
now when he arrives here of course his
ship is intercepted by Batman and
Superman and then they basically bring
the ship back down to earth now a couple
things to explain here number one this
kid starts talking about hyper time and
two one of the world's world's finest
and why are Batman and Superman teaming
up all right to the second question
Batman and Superman teaming up and the
world's finest Comics have been a thing
ever since the old world finest Comics
back in the 1940s Batman and Superman
were just the most popular characters
that DC had so DC has said let's put
them in a book and have them team up and
they've basically been doing it off and
on ever since and it just makes good
sense from a business perspective to the
first question talking about the idea of
hyper time this is a ridiculously
Antiquated concept that DC has only
recently tried to make sense of in Jon
Stewart Emerald Knight number one so you
guys know how sometimes something takes
place in comics and it leads to an
alternate reality a really good example
of this is in the flashpoint storyline
when Superman lands on Earth but is
immediately taken by the federal
government and then held underground
exposed to a red Sun constantly so his
powers never develop that's a whole
different alternate reality what Jon
Stewart Emerald Night number one did in
explaining hyper time is it said
sometimes there are change that happen
in the time stream that are not enough
to create a whole new alternate reality
but are different from what goes on in
the main DC Universe it just kind of
fits in there right in between now why
DC is doing that I don't know hyper time
needs to go away it's unnecessary DC
created it after they got rid of the
Multiverse and crisis on infinite Earth
as a way to basically tell stories that
could kind of be multiversal stories but
there's not really a Multiverse so
there's no multiverses to tell stories
about it's weird it's unnecessary they
need to get rid of it the important
thing here though is that hyper time
being what it is it was studied by the
people in Gotham City in this alternate
reality specifically the parents of this
kit now the funny thing here is that
this kid whose name is David basically
says that the idea behind the rocket
ship is it was going to be an
experimental vessel that it was going to
be a vessel that was going to be sent
through the Multiverse in an effort to
explore the Multiverse itself that's
something that DC's been doing ever
since the events of dark crisis the
Multiverse is back it's bigger than it's
ever been and there's more alternate
reality Earth that are around there and
even some old realities have basically
come back so DC has been doing a lot of
exploring on that front with NDC comics
and so while David was only on one
vessel there were supposed to be others
but with the world coming to an end they
basically turned the vessel into a life
raft and then sent him away in order to
survive now the reason why this is so
important is because David's Powers
immediately start manifesting as soon as
he arrives here and quite literally his
body just starts generating massive
amounts of heat and just let off this
massive explosion and so there's two
things that happen here the first is
that Batman and Superman deduced that
David being exposed to the yellow sun
that much like Superman basically starts
sitting his powers into overdrive but
with him not knowing how to handle his
abilities and not even fully
understanding what they are he presents
a clear and present danger to basically
everybody around him but the other part
of this is that as he tells his origin
story to Superman and Batman Superman
realizes David's story is almost exactly
like his own and so there's a kind of
kinship that forms between the two of
them because in a lot of ways Superman
sort of wishes there had been somebody
that he could talk to in order to
understand how he can fit into the world
such as it is he never had that there
was no one Superman could go to to
basically help guide him and make sense
of his time here on Earth and how his
powers are working and so on and so
forth there was no mentor and so
Superman sees himself as a potential
Mentor for David and so Batman of course
as you guys know is always skeptical of
everybody and so he's literally looking
at this kid David like something's a
little off about this kid I should do
some detective work and figure out what
it is and so while he's doing that
Superman takes David to the bottled city
of Candor now for those of you guys who
don't understand this Mythos the bottled
city of Candor has been part of the
Superman stories for decades and the
idea behind this really just goes back
to a guy named Brainiac that in the
early days of DC Comics when Brainiac
was originally introduced his Big Mo is
that he would travel around the universe
and he would capture entire city and
then shrink them down and bottle them up
and so Candor was a Kryptonian city that
was shrunk and bottled by Brainiac
before Krypton was completely eradicated
Superman eventually discovered it and
the origins of how he discovered Krypton
have been retold over the years in DC
but within Krypton are just a whole host
of kryptonians and so by bringing David
to Candor it allows the candorian
scientists to actually study David to
better understand how his powers work
and even devise a suit that would allow
him to control his own abilities and so
following that Batman chimes in and says
that he's found David's parents now this
is kind of a messed up moment in the
comics I'm not gonna lie I mean I kind
of laughed a little bit but it's also
Twisted at the same time when Batman and
Superman bring David to where his
parents reside in this universe Batman
initially tries to warn David of
something but David doesn't listen he
immediately takes off and goes to see
these people and he just kind of grabs
him and hugs them and says it's me your
son I haven't seen you in so long and
that kind of a thing and they
immediately get angry right and that
leads to David basically taking off
because from his perspective his parents
don't recognize him now that's when
Batman chimes in and says what I was
trying to tell you is that yes these
people are this reality's version of
your parents but their child died like
years ago right when he was just like a
toddler that kid died so you running up
on them and telling them like I'm your
long-lost son kind of disrupts the
healing process that they were trying to
go through and it just seems like a
crazy terrible evil thing for a person
to do but it's one of those things where
he's kind of told your life as you know
it is more or less over it's basically
done which is a pretty crushing
experience for this kid and this is one
of the reasons why robin is one of the
best characters ever in DC Comics
because what ends up happening is Robin
just kind of sits down and says this kid
needs some normalcy right you guys are
basically trying to teach him to
understand his situation and so on and
so forth what he needs is to believe he
can fit in somewhere he needs to believe
that he can find some measure of a home
here and so what he does is he takes him
to meet the Teen Titans now here's the
thing the Teen Titans right like I mean
they've got some dark stories don't get
me wrong the Teen Titans have some dark
stories and DC Comics I mean some
terrible stuff has happened to this team
but they're like the most fun ever like
if I were a teenager and I had powers
the Teen Titans is like the first group
I'd want to go hang out with so it's one
of those things where like when he's
brought to the Teen Titans it's
basically Robin and the Gang saying hey
look come hang out with us now the Teen
Titans are really cool in this way
because they have their own history the
Teen Titans was originally composed of a
team who were all basically Sidekicks of
the bigger superheroes now over the
years they've developed a massive
audience they've become immensely
popular but what we also end up finding
out here is there's a much bigger game
afoot that behind the scenes of all this
stuff is a villain known as the key now
we'll talk about him here in a second
because he is arguably one of the most
powerful villains that you've never
heard of and I love what DC is doing
with this character but initially David
hanging out with the Teen Titans it just
looks like the most fun ever because
what they're doing is like testing his
powers like how fast can you move right
so like Speedy who was at one point the
sidekick of Green Arrow like fires off a
boxing glove arrow and the idea is to
like catch it or Dodge out of the way or
something like that ultimately he just
gets hit in the face I mean he doesn't
end up like destroying it but like he
also kind of gets hit in the face that
sort of thing but in a lot of ways what
the Teen Titans realize is that his
powers are just reacting instinctively
but more so than that and one of the
cool things about this here is that
while David doesn't necessarily know it
the Teen Titans are kind of putting him
through a training regimen figuring out
how his powers work figuring out how his
mind works how stable he is that kind of
thing it's a pretty smart way to get an
understanding of where this guy fits
into everything now the bigger problem
here is that while he should be spending
time with the Teen Titans of course
there is a kind of emergency that's
taking place here now the funny thing
and this is something that I that I
absolutely loved when the key is brought
in who is the one behind this big
emergency he's almost kind of brought in
is like a ridiculous villain of the week
and not someone you would take serious
because as his name suggests the key is
able to like unlock and lock locks right
control access to different areas so
this guy basically locks down the
building and then initiate these
emergencies across the city and there's
like no firemen to respawn and he's like
if you want your City to survive you
will give me five billion dollars in
untraceable currency I mean it's the
least interesting plot ever it's kind of
cool I'm gonna be honest right a guy who
can just like shut down people's ability
to access doors but Batman is Superman
swoop in quite readily and start
evacuating people and the plans of the
key go up in smoke pretty fast but
what's also interesting here is that
David is just sort of thrust into the
situation right he's just sort of
brought into this whole thing and his
task is to basically try to help people
save people as best he can now he's not
familiar with this and in fact what he's
told is that there is a mine out there
that's basically been shut down but
within this mine is methane gas and the
miners cannot Escape because of the
actions of the key so the job of David
is to travel to the mine and basically
find a way to get the door open so that
these miners can survive the problem
with this is that as most of the guys
know methane gas is highly flammable and
with David's Powers being that he just
lets off massive amounts of heat the
potential issue here is walking into a
methane gas filled chamber with a lit
match right you're going to blow
yourself to pieces and you're going to
kill everybody and everything in there
and in fact that's David's concern right
where he initially tries to unlock the
door using an emergency latch it doesn't
quite work and then in turn he's told by
Batman you're going to have to smash the
door down or you're gonna have to use
your powers and below the door apart but
you have to be precise just enough of
your powers to get the door to unlock
but not so much that your powers
accidentally blast into the room and
blow everybody to Smithereens and in
fact David actually panics in Dale right
he freaks out and he ultimately ends up
abandoning the whole thing and taking
off now the cool thing about this is
that he basically starts to kind of look
Inward and even reflect on his own
history with his parents the world
falling apart the world basically dying
everything ending the fact that he fled
from like helping save the life of a guy
who needed his help and in seeing
himself as a coward ends up traveling
back to the building and in fact tearing
the door apart and then in that moment
when Superman arrives to basically get
the door open where David couldn't he
ends up finding that David has the door
open as well and so in the face of the
keys plot right his entire scheme
basically coming to an end that what he
ends up doing is meeting with his
partner the person that we didn't
actually know was working with him
behind the scenes and what we find out
here is the partner of the key is none
other than the Joker and as you guys
know the Joker realizes that David is
basically the new sidekick of Superman
and anybody who knows anything about the
Joker knows just how much this guy loves
Sidekicks specifically he loves to kill
him so here's the question you got to
ask yourself what happens when it comes
down to Batman and Superman having to
fight the Joker because I will tell you
guys this much things are about to pop
off but with that being said we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace